vous êtes converti au judaïsme pour
l'épouser non enfin oui j'suis con
virtualis mais pas parce spécialement
pour l'épouser vous êtes un bon juif
oui on va voir interview bon j'ai alors
gagné en quelle année juive sommes-nous
5766 braves est ce que vous connaissez
les cinq grandes fêtes juives
louisa bonne blague bien cela qui pousse
way recherche and away pessah pâques
noël parce que jésus était juif était
une soupe côté chats watts ou pas des
chats boîte voilà mais c'est bien déjà
moi je trouve que vous avez bien vous
avez bien appris est ce que vous allez
fêter noël quand même cette année noël
rannou temps les deux ouais comment
dit-on bonne année shana tova dia à
quelle heure est il s'est arrêté de
bosser le vendredi ça dépend où coucher
du soleil
dac vous trouvez drôle le nouveau
spectacle de dieudonné je trouve ça
triste je trouve qu'il est plus drôle du
tout est justement en parlant d' extrême
et d'extrémisme par rapport au
conditionnement des gens et par rapport
à genève je trouve qu'il est justement
dans cet excédent cet extrémisme et que
c'est désespérant de le voir s'enfoncer
tout seul
comment appelle-t-on dieu chez les juifs
à gauche m art n'a pas le droit de dire
seulement deux chaînes absolument d
adosser un dc non soumises aux patrons
un seul son que marc la circoncision
l'alliance avec abraham ça fait mal
j'étais déjà circoncis moi oui c'est moi
et comme je suis en fait j'ai eu deux
les trois religions mathieu gellé
modestie c'est à dire que le mon père
était kabyle
donc c'est un mélange de religion
musulmane et juive
ouais parce que dans kabylie a une dent
une reine qui s'appelle la kahina d une
grande reine juive
voilà ma ma mère et fille timide ouais
donc du coup j'ai été circoncis enfants
et j'ai fait aussi ma communion c'est
bien donc je rassemble son jeu rassemble
belgique
c'est un peu la même chose les fêtes en
vacances toute l'année voilà alors dany
qui est isaac à part d'être le barman de
la croisière s'amuse
c'est le fils d'abraham isaac et jacob
sont les trois dans quel coin moïse at
il reçu les tables de la loi 100 sur
mont sinaï
c'est quoi le talmud
le talmud c'est une réflexion écrite des
deux qui depuis des siècles sur la torah
en fait ça explique la torah et ça ça
pose les questions sur la torah la torah
qui est qui et le livre de dieu quoi
l'habit blanc fait enfin donnée par dieu
aux hommes c'est bien vous y connaissez
vachement bien qu'est ce qu'on fait à
hanouka
c'est une fait beaucoup pour les surtout
pour les enfants on leur fait un cadeau
parfait donc les enfants adorent et
manger des rillettes
non je ne mange pas une ruse pour manger
encore du homard nom du lapin vous en
mangez des lapins aviaire c'est bien non
qu'est ce t'en penses il a bossé en
aucun cas un moins bon jus non mais
c'est là m'intéressent mais c'est venu
en fait aussi beaucoup par map six ans
j'ai une psy qui est très juive
ashkénaze et je me suis beaucoup
intéressé à la psychanalyse est la
psychanalyse tire ses sources justement
du thème de la torah c'est une sorte de
judaïsme laïque
bravo dany boon joaillier de questions
guillaume canadienne suggère le bim à
voir